An integral part of the game, immediately
prior to the start of play, the football quarterback
begins his cadence.
More than just “hut,” the offensive leader
on the field uses short commands to prepare
the team, adjust to the defense’s line up
and even change the play.
Whether it’s “53 is the Mike,” “Omaha,”
“Red 32,” “Set” or “Hike,” each
shout is an important tool in the quarterback’s
bag of tricks.
The Short Words
The most well known cadence, “hike,” was
the brainchild of John Heisman (of the eponymous
trophy).
Prior to its introduction, commonly the quarterback
signaled the center to give him the ball by
simply scratching the center’s leg.
During the 1890-1891 season, Heisman was playing
center for the University of Pennsylvania
when a leg scratch from an opposing player
tricked into hiking early.
To fix the problem, Heisman introduced using
a word to start the snap, and that it be “hike,”
which already meant to lift up and also had
the added benefit of being a short, sharp
sound.
“Hut” was a later introduction, although
by the 1950s it was commonly in use in football.
Linguists trace its origins back to military
cadence, particularly of World War II, when
drill sergeants would holler “Atten-hut!”
Another short, sharp sound, it was perfect
for preparing the team for battle.
Sharply yelling single syllable words to get
attention has a long history.
Early on, animals were directed with such
commands (and still are today) and common
locutions included “hup,” “hip” and
“hep” (with “hup” dating back to the
18th century).
Other short football commands include “set,”
after which the linemen get into their stance,
and “move” which may direct many players
to adjust according to a planned shift, or
could just stir a few to action (e.g., the
tight ends assume a 3-point stance).
Longer Phrases
Colors and numbers are frequently used in
combination, such as “Green 19,” “Blue
82” and “43-2,” for any number of reasons.
Sometimes, the phrase indicates an audible
(change in play called at the line of scrimmage
to adjust to a troubling defensive scheme),
and other times, it clues players in to their
blocking assignments.
Often the phrase will put a receiver in motion
or simply designate when the ball is about
to be snapped.
And frequently, a great deal of it (if not
all at times) is gibberish.
Typically, a team will have a live color – after
hearing this color, offensive players know
the predetermined snap count (the number of
“huts” after which the ball will be hiked)
is about to begin (e.g., “Green 32, Green
32, hut hut.”)
Even though one color is live, other colors
will be used (gibberish), to distract and
confuse the defense, and sometimes even to
cause them to jump offsides if used with a
hard count (e.g. if green is the live color,
“Blue 18, Blue 18, hut, hut, HUT hut.”)
The live color can be any color, although
according to Brett Favre, “a lot of teams
use black or red as a hot.
When you hear that, there’s an audible coming.”
Nonetheless, as he concludes, “everyone’s
different.”
Another typical cadence denotes ” the Mike.”
Traditionally, “Mike” was shorthand for
the middle linebacker, and a common cadence
heard in the NFC North (and before that the
Central) from 2000-2012 was “54 has the
Mike.”
However, several commentators note that this
phrase is not necessarily applied to the Mike,
but to the defensive player that requires
special attention – such as who the fullback
should block.
A cadence that comes in many forms but generally
means the same thing is the word(s) used to
indicate a change in the snap count.
Peyton and Eli Manning sometimes use “Omaha,”
(Eli says Peyton stole it from him), and Tom
Brady uses “Alpha.”
Defenses are wise to this use, and in fact
during a 2009 Giants-Dallas game, Eli used
it too much – to the point where Chris Collinsworth
thought he was tipping the snap.
Adjusting yet again, now these quarterbacks
use “Omaha” and “Alpha” in other ways,
such as when Peyton began incorporating it
into his hard count (with great success, apparently).
In order to clue the offense in, they will
have established a “freeze” word that
he yells before “Omaha,” so no offensive
players move, but the defense jumps.
Football insiders Randy Moss and Brian Urlacher
have a different take on “Omaha,” and
though it was used to direct the offense to
run the planned play, but in the opposite
direction.
A Rise in Gibberish
Fans have noticed an upswing in chatter from
quarterbacks over the last several years,
and most believe this is due to placing microphones
on centers and guards in 2011.
Used by the networks to bring the sounds of
the game to the viewers, prior to 2010, the
official, who was positioned in the defensive
backfield, wore the on-field microphone.
After 2010, the official was placed in the
offensive backfield (due to safety concerns),
but with the quarterback’s back to him,
many sounds were muffled before it reached
the mic.
The solution: wire up some offensive lineman.
Another example of unintended consequences,
now every code and cue uttered by the quarterback
is clearly audible to everyone, including
defensive players and coordinators.
As a result, defenses were better able to
decode cadences, which, once again, stirred
offenses to adapt – now with a combination
of hand signals, gesticulations and a great
deal of meaningless chatter to hide the few
important code words.
As one veteran defensive lineman noted: “He’s
holding up two finders . . . calling out all
these colors, ‘purple, blue’ . . . it’s
funny . . . when you see someone on TV jump
offisdes . . . but the fact of the matter
is that you get out there on Sunday and it
could happen
to you.”